really know who you people are and know
who you can trust and know who's there
for you 24/7 in just six years
Jojo SIA has gone from Dance Moms to a
worldwide sensation and her signature
hair bow has never left her side it
might sound crazy since she has her own
empire and everything but dodo actually
has to follow a ton of rules check out
the rest of the video to find out all
about how Nickelodeon make sure that she
always stays straight on the path to
mega stardom it seems like Jojo runs her
own empire entirely right from her daily
YouTube videos to her concerts for
upwards of 20,000 fans it appears from
the outside like Jojo is totally in
control but actually she is just the
face at the forefront of a huge Jojo C
WA machine owned and operated by
Nickelodeon the first step she took on
the way to mega stardom was signing what
is called an overall talent deal with
Nickelodeon when she was only 13 years
old and with that the company took
ownership over everything Jojo sua
seriously everything even her social
media is controlled by the TV
Corporation we know it's a little sad to
find out that Jojo isn't really running
her own socials but it's true
Tina's how her contract extends to
everything about her they keep a very
strict hold over what Jojo posts and
shares on every single social media
platform with a team of PR people who
carefully curate the content of her
YouTube videos they can make sure that
not a single posts can stray from the
Jojo Siva image while it's still Jojo
who appears in the videos and photos her
contract forbids her from going rogue
and posting whatever she feels like that
means that while she can express some
opinions we'll never really know what
she is actually thinking or feeling ever
since I was a kid
literally when I was three years old and
I saw her in Montana I was like I wanna
be Hannah Montana Jojo has been a
natural performer since the day she
could walk but that doesn't mean she was
always interested in making music
actually her entire music career is also
part of her talent contract with
Nickelodeon she didn't sing or produce a
single song until after she had signed
with Nick and that's no accident she
had to in order to make sure she was
reaching as many fans as possible
Nickelodeon made Jojo start her music
career that way instead of going the way
of her Dance Moms co-star Maddie Ziegler
and sticking to the world of
professional dancing Jojo could go on to
stadium tours and start raking in the
big bucks while she obviously loves
performing and singing her songs to her
fans her whole music career is all part
of the contract and if she had never
signed it her career might look totally
different today
[Music]
Jojo has been open about wanting to be a
role model for young kids and not to go
the same way as many other 16 year old
stars like her
some people have wondered why she act so
young instead of breaking free like
Miley Cyrus or ariana grande and the
real reason is is that she's not allowed
to along with controlling what she can
and cannot say in public JoJo's contract
is super strict about how she can behave
in order to prevent her from going the
way of so many pop stars turned party
girls they carefully monitored JoJo's
behavior including where she can go and
what she can be seen doing she is
forbidden from swearing and expressing
political or otherwise controversial
opinions she is definitely not allowed
to be seen partying or engaging in
mature activities that most teenage
stars are usually allowed to get away
with Jojo is absolutely forbidden from
vaping or using tobacco products which
is actually one rule that we totally
understand because her image is so
squeaky clean and her fan base ranges
from 4 to 14 years old dodo knows that
whenever she was caught doing her fans
are going to try and copy or they'll go
the other way and be less than happy
with her about it oh yeah and it's also
in her contracts that she has to smile
when we think of Jojo Silla the first
thing that comes to mind is her hair her
super blonde super tight side ponytail
with its super present beau has become
JoJo's signature look but it has fans
wondering why doesn't she ever let her
hair down well Jojo claims that she's
happier with her hair off of her neck
which is totally fair but now that it's
a look that millions of fans try to copy
she pretty much can't take it down and
don't even think for one second that
she'd be allowed to rock her natural
brown locks JoJo's mom jessalyn started
bleaching her daughter's hair when she
was around five years old and hasn't
stopped since
now her platinum blonde locks are such a
sensation that she isn't allowed to
stray from her usual look and that
doesn't just stop at her hairstyle
either the rules on what she can and
cannot look like extend to her entire
image her clothes are all carefully
selected to keep up with the Jojo
co-brand her glittery rainbow colored
outfits are all part of the Jojo look
and she isn't allowed to deviate from it
one of the reasons for this is that
whatever her fans see her wearing
they'll want to wear for themselves and
since Jojo has her own clothing and
accessory lines at Target and Claire's
they can go out and pick out outfits
that match their favorite superstar so
if Jojo stops wearing her famous
multicolored outfits her fans will too
it's all Nickelodeon's way of keeping
the Sawada tours heading out to the mall
and spending their hard-earned
allowances on everything Jojo sua which
of course extends to the most Jojo item
of all her bows
Jojo said that she has sold over 40
million bows in the last year and that
doesn't seem to be slowing down anytime
soon because Jojo isn't like any other
popstar who appears on stage she needs
the perfect house to go along with her
image since she spends so much time
filming YouTube videos in her home it's
natural that her house would need to
look a certain way but not just nice it
has to keep up with the Jojo see what
brand not only does it have to have her
famous Jojo convertible parked out front
the inside is completely branded with
her Jojo sua image and a wall of her
Jojo juice on display in a junk food
filled room she calls the fun room she
also has a merch room that is completely
filled with
every single piece of merchandise that
Jojo has ever created it must be funny
to be another family member who isn't
Jojo living in a totally do household
from food to bedding to plates to party
supplies for apparel to jewelry to toys
to electronics we've talked a lot about
her contract with Nickelodeon and how it
covers pretty much every aspect of her
life so it isn't all that surprising to
learn that Jojo is absolutely not
allowed to work with anyone else that
hasn't dealt exclusively with the
company that means that Jojo is
forbidden from appearing in TV shows or
movies that aren't made by Nickelodeon
and she isn't allowed to release any
music that isn't also a Nickelodeon
product so if she has any passion
projects and minds that the Nickelodeon
executives aren't on board with she'll
just have to wait until her contract
ends to get to work on them well we
don't know when her contract is up we
can't imagine that Nick will be letting
go of their biggest star anytime soon
and hey it's worked out pretty well for
Jojo so far chances are she is happy to
follow these rules as long as it means
that she keeps getting to do what she
loves while you might think that Jojo is
just being her natural bubbly self at
all times she has actually had to work
pretty hard to refine her public persona
as part of her deal upon signing with
Nickelodeon Jojo was put through an
intensive media training class that was
all about how to control her image in
the public eye it wasn't just Jojo
either all child stars who come up
through Disney Nickelodeon or any other
major studio have to go through the same
kind of training Jojo always had to
sparkly entertaining side of her
personality down but through these
classes she learned how to speak to
adults in a more grown-up fashion as
someone who is constantly being
interviewed on camera she needed to be
able to talk to reporters and TV hosts
in a mature way in order to prove to the
parents of the world that she is a good
role model for their kids these classes
also taught her how to sit properly how
much to smile and what kind of language
she can use when speaking on camera
when Jojo posted a photo of herself and
a boy in early 2020 fans and reporters
everywhere lost their minds and suddenly
the question came up is Jojo allowed to
date she went on to clarify that the boy
named Eliot Brown is a longtime family
friend and while her family has often
joked about how they would be cute
together she didn't really get into the
specifics of their relationship but in a
later interview when asked about whether
or not she is allowed to date the answer
became pretty clear or not so clear she
said that if she came to her mom and
told her that she liked a boy and she
wanted to date him that her mom would
say no but also Jojo says her mom claims
that if it was the right boy and the
situation was appropriate that she might
be more open to it and then don't you
again said that even though her mom
might claim to be okay with it that the
answer would still be no while those
answers are both a bit confusing one
thing is clear Jojo isn't allowed to
date Nickelodeon might technically have
the rights to JoJo's entire life but
it's been obvious from the very
beginning that her mom runs the show
this apparently means that even though
Jojo is 16 years old a perfectly normal
age for kids to start dating she has to
go to her mom for approval which she
knows she won't get of course Jojo is
also incredibly busy and says that she
has no time or interest in meeting boys
so things are working out for the
megastar for now and that's a wrap what
do you think about jessalyn strict no
dating rule should dodo be allowed to
date like other girls her age or would
that ruin her brand tell us in the
comments don't focus on that one person
who's being mean to you focus on the 10
other nice people crazy rules Jojo sua
must follow thanks for watching
subscribe to the things for more fun
content and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up
you